alors bonjour à tous ici stéphane parent
de radio canada international nous
sommes aujourd'hui journée
extraordinaire jeudi vous palais des
congrès devant rien pour le 6e salon de
l'immigration et l'intégration du québec
alors on est invité ici on est évité
depuis hier de belle manière
nous avons déjà réalisé trois émissions
spéciales vous avec mon sujet en cinq
langues vivantes aujourd'hui vous aurez
droit sur facebook en live à la version
française de la du canada est en
national et puis dans une couple
d'heures à la version anglaise
alors bien sûr il ya beaucoup de monde
ici autour de la table des visages que
vous reconnaissez penche un peu la tête
il ya lire gimeno qui est notre
webmestre principal à radio canada
international qui est avec nous il ya
aussi une équipe technique qui est qui
se cache derrière lors leur appareil
pour regarder sur facebook à quoi ça
ressemble cette émission spéciale de
radio canada international
je ne vous les présente pas mais je vous
présente d'avoir notre invité d'honneur
il s'agit de marseille-fos sur bonjour
tout le monde
l'on appelle le co animateur de cette
émission spéciale parce que
finalement tu va l'être effectivement tu
aimes éditeur de radio canada
international depuis des années c'est
pour ça que je ne peux m'empêcher
nautique loyer je ne fais pas exprès je
devrais que vous voyez c'est la méthode
radio canadienne mais tu es un ami de
tony et on a une idée de te demander de
venir ici au salon de tester ce que le
salon à offrir pour augmenter ses
chances de décrocher un emploi
merci propos jettent et résonneront on
va parler de mon expérience personnelle
et de ton parcours aujourd'hui notamment
avec christophe berthet vice président
du salon de l'immigration et la
direction du québec qui est avec nous
bonjour bonjour stéphane j'ai reçu un
message de votre présidente ce matin
d'un ça va très bien 4500 personnes et
vous êtes et la deuxième journée du
salon parce qu'un à deux c'est toujours
un peu plus grand au niveau de
l'achalandage je crois oui oui c'est
vrai que c'est beaucoup plus grands on a
changé un peu le format puisque on
faisait ça le vendredi et samedi les
quatre premières éditions
on s'est rendu compte il ya un peu moins
de monde le samedi et depuis qu'on fait
ça en semaine sur deux jours en effet
hier et aujourd'hui on se rend compte
qu'en semaine le deuxième jour est
généralement plus achalandés mais il ya
aussi tout un événement protocolaire le
matin qui fait que ça il ya beaucoup
d'achalandage avec notamment la chambre
de commerce de montréal qui présente
avec morale internationale
oui et nos importants partenaires au 6
mai mais quelle belle molliet vous
faites avec votre prochaine éviter ici
autour de la table on va venir revenir
avec vous en conversation dans quelques
instants mais il faut absolument
présenter hubert bolduc qui est depuis
le pdg de morgan internationale c'est un
organisme quel radio-canada nationale
est familier parce que souvent on fait
des articles aux coûts sujet de la
dimension internationale de montréal et
votre organisme joue un rôle central
pour développer cette image du plan
international absolument nous on ne le
mandat - l'international de d'attirer et
de retenir et d'accueillir des
organisations internationales
ce talent international et les
investissements directs étrangers
donc on est vraiment au coeur de
l'activité internationale de montréal
qu'est ce que vous venez faire ici au
salon aujourd'hui peut être dans le
mandat de d'attraction et de rétention
des étudiants internationaux
montréal des temps nationale joue un
rôle pivot en ce sens que nous avons
fait une étude il ya un an qui
démontrait que sur les 32 mille
étudiants internationaux qui venaient
faire des études à montréal
la moitié avait des intentions de
demeurer après des études que ce soit
baccalauréat maîtrise dr
malheureusement sur la moitié qui avait
des intentions de rester on en garde et
seulement ainsi qu'un donc à peu près du
musée sans trois mais nous avons des
mouvements ont présenté cette étude du
gouvernement et nous leur avons dit au
coin chez moi un terrain qu'on est
capable potentiellement de tripler le
nombre d'étudiants internationaux qui
demeurent après des études il ya combien
15 mai on voudrait à lire environ
l'objectif sur trois ans est de passer
de 3000 à 9000 de passer d'un projet de
vie étudiante à un projet de vie
complète et ce salon est une expo est
une possibilité pour nous de justement
tenter de convaincre ses titres
internationaux de rester la clef c'est
l'expérience du travail pour qu'il reste
un jour du stage en entreprise je pense
que vous avez vous êtes sur un filon
leur exactement mon pied droit de trois
obstacles sont plus humains ici à là
au maintien d'un étudiant ainsi le
premier ces îles sont pas dans l'aude
pour la lente
oui à la fois le français mais aussi
l'anglais parce que la plupart des
immigrants qui minent ici par trois la
bombarde le français vont parler dans le
vide puisque l'animateur ne peuvent dans
le premier le second c'est la question
de la complexité du système
d'immigration mais tout semble indiquer
que dans deux semaines on devrait avoir
des réponses assez positive la part du
gouvernement fédéral à cet effet pour
faciliter le processus de migration pour
le rendre plus simple et le troisième
vous l'avait bien dit si toute la
question de
de l'emploi donc comment pouvons-nous
nous assurer que ces étudiants puissent
avoir accès à un stage avoir une
expérience québécoise de travail ou
montréalaise de travail ce qui va
faciliter considérablement par la suite
leur embauche après leurs études
je sais que depuis quelques années
notamment l'université laval
s'intéresse beaucoup aux cas de ces
étudiants qui fuit entre les mains qui
semble qu'ils retournent et tout un
projet pour aider l'adaptation et ce
salon s'appelle non seulement le salon
des migrations mais de l'intégration
c'est important au niveau du défi
d'intégration est ce que montréal
international prévoit des liens avec les
universités qui des gens essaye
d'accomplir une partie de ce travail de
rétention aux employés politiques
on espère mais des étudiants étrangers
nous on est vraiment sur la rétention
des étudiants internationaux je sais que
le gouvernement dans ses cartons un
projet de faire de la traction de
profiter du fait que moi la gagne et
merville universitaire au monde pour
faire ses études donc c'est un autre
aspect de la question notre action nous
la rétention c'est vraiment s'assurer
que ils prennent des cours de français
qui prennent des cours d'anglais
s'assurer que on les accompagne vraiment
dans les processus d'émigration et
s'assurer et dans le dakota ce salon de
faciliter leur embauche
c'est ce ceci dans ce périmètre là que
se définit l'action de moyens en
personnel pour le reste d'autres
organisations ceux qui font d'autres
choses tout à fait tout aussi important
mais nous on se concentre sur 6 3
vous avez fait le tour du salon pas peur
qu'est ce que les gens vous demandent où
vous dise dans le cas de notre kiosque
nous on est et on a convaincu des
entreprises des grandes entreprise
montréalaise et québécoise de venir
s'asseoir dans nos kiosques et de
répondre aux questions et de proposer
des stages de proposer des offres donc
on est une comme expérience hier on va
voir ce que ça va me donner plus tard
aujourd'hui mais on pourra parler
davantage à l'issue du salon mais de ce
qu'on se dit ce matin la réponse est
exacte
les fantastiques hubert bolduc pdg de
marianne est en national vous allez
mener ou poursuivre votre mission à
travers ce salon vous avez d'autres
obligations donc on vous laisse filer
ses permissions spéciales mais vous
reviendrez an prochain si on peut ou
lancer des jeunes invitation avec les
états parce que nous ici à radio canada
international on sent vraiment qu'il ya
un lien il ya une infinité amicales
professionnelles bien sûr ici une limite
d'amitié on peut faire beaucoup de
choses
merci beaucoup à vous et christian ça se
produira deux fois vous ne direz deux
fois pendant des mois alors dites moi au
niveau d'aidé de convaincre les
entreprises d'offrir des stages de
formation ces choses là qu'est ce que
vous avez prévu on mettre en contact les
gens qui viennent ici c'est dix mille
personnes qui étaient là l'an dernier je
pense qu'elle avait dix mille foyers qui
cherchait des solutions pour trouver de
l'emploi
qu'est ce que vous leur offrez
précisément au niveau des kiosques dit
vous avez des stands spéciaux je pense
alors oui oui
on a des stands spéciaux en effet qu'ils
font notamment du rappel recrutement
express donc des entreprises qui sont
qui délègue des personnes des ressources
humaines pour rencontrer très rapidement
vraiment dans le cas de trois minutes à
faire un premier entretien
je pense d'ailleurs que marcia on a eu à
voir discuter un peu avec lui il pourra
nous raconter son expérience mais voilà
l'idée c'est c'est vraiment de pouvoir
parler à quelqu'un de pouvoir se
présenter
et puis de pouvoir briser peut-être un
petit peu la glace parce que aujourd'hui
on se rend compte
on envoie un cv par internet on n'a pas
forcément de retour ça permet aussi
d'avoir peut-être un retour direct d'un
employeur potentiel qui peut dire bon
ben voila je comprends bien mais
regardez vous devriez vous présentez
comme ça faire comme ça donc voilà ça
permet au moins de rencontrer des
professionnels d'avoir un juste première
expérience question
enfin petite pause ici mais pas musicale
dispose pour annoncer ici sur les
haut-parleurs qui a des gens qui veulent
participer à cette émission spéciale de
radio canada international on le sait
vous nous avez parlé durant l'émission
il ya maintenant deux places de libres
alors si vous appartenez à un groupe
d'exposants ici je pense à parcs canada
je pense une association ici qui
s'appelle al arabiya québec
je sais que vous êtes intéressés à venir
participer de mission il ya deux places
disponibles les premiers arrivés seront
les premiers servis comme ça que
fonctionne je suis extrêmement content
d'avoir un autre trois atouts 3 est ce
qu'on peut dire en le pari d'un
troisième co animateur c'est vraiment
je n'irai pas jusque là stéphane hains
je vous le présente c'est un vieil ami
luc simard arad qui on dira pas combien
d'années parce que ça va ou vieillir
inutilement mais et un certain nombre
d'années on a commencé notre carrière
comment c'était le cas en alberta à une
émission vous dérapez l'autre jour
dessous de plus d'une heure d'émission à
moi je m'en souviens ouais première page
ben oui et on avait là bas c'était vous
qui avez l'art de poser des questions
difficiles vous est cuisinier vos
invités moi j'étais d'animateurs dont
j'étais le gars gentil vous étiez le bad
caf missionnée à plus de ça c'est
fantastique vous ne vous retrouvez
aujourd'hui vous représentez radio
canada et si l'on donne votre titre
officiel on va comprendre ici en bonne
partie
quelle est votre mission vous êtes le
directeur de la diversité des relations
citoyennes de radio canada
c'est un poste qui est relativement
nouveau ça fait quelques années que ça
existe et ce n'est pas un poste à temps
plein à leur usma réseau canada jeu
malheureusement parce que il y aurait
suffisamment de travail à faire pour en
faire quoi s'attendre et donc c'est un
post à demi temps j'ai eu un autre mythe
us we
originaire du secteur de l'information
je suis journaliste essentiellement et
j'étais responsable de sur des missions
d'information
mais il faut dire que l'enjeu de la
diversité puis les enjeux d'information
se se retrouvent n'est ce pas son
commune la preuve en est votre émission
ce que vous faites ici au salon on voit
bien qu'il est important à la fois non
seulement de 2,2 d'informer le public
sur ces enjeux de l'immigration en
particulier mais également pour
radio-canada ça ces mêmes partis donc
comme directeur la diversité d'aller à
la rencontre des citoyens d'aller à la
rencontre des gens qu'on voit ici qui
sont parfois des immigrants récents mais
parfois aussi des immigrants pas si
récente et qui dans les deux écoles de
toute manière son autre public
alors c'est notre public que nous
voulons rencontrer ici donc depuis hier
il ya des différents responsables de
réseau des artistes viennent ici
simplement pour parler de radio-canada
et discuter avec les gens qui se
présentent à notre stade où je vous
parle seulement deux minutes mais vous
allez vous rester parce qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui on aimerait vous parler
c'est notre invité mystère je passe
s'ils voyaient à côté de vous serez
invité mystère donc on révélera le
secret dans quelques minutes je l'espère
et il tient absolument à vous parler de
la condition et comment ils pourraient
vous aider
et puis barre c'est aussi à eux nous
doit vous donner mon co animateur marc
si on s'en vient dans quelques instants
mais d'abord un autre personnage très
important qui est pressé qui devra nous
quitte et relativement rapidement et il
est avec nous pour cette émission
spéciale on le remercie infiniment alors
il s'agit de harout chitilian qui
vice-présidente du comité exécutif de la
ville de montréal bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes vous êtes le premier
politicien à cette table et vous arrivez
pas la langue de bois vous est présentée
ici présenté deux choses notamment la
plus importante je pense une des plus
importantes ce serait quand il ya
seulement deux choses le jour où les
plus importants il ya le binam donc le
bureau d'intégration nous immigrants
montréal qui a réalisé une enquête et
vous avez annoncé les résultats hier
après-midi en qu'est ce que vous avez à
nous annoncer ou à nous à nous présenter
au niveau de ce qui se passe pour les
nouveaux arrivants historiens qui
cherchent du travail absolument donc
avant tout c'est une approche qui est
personnalisé parce que le sondage devait
servait à actualiser l'offre de services
de la ville de montréal et surtout de
cibler les groupes qui ont vraiment
besoin de notre accompagnement parce que
les données sont probants et démontre
que ceux qui ont le statut de résidents
permanents font leurs devants il se
prépare et ils viennent ici préparer
pour affronter l'intégration alors que
vous avez 68 mille personnes qui sont
des résidents temporaires mais qui ont
un intérêt à rester ici soit ils sont
des étudiants étrangers sur cd visitant
qui veulent rester s'il soit c'est des
travailleurs qui sont hissés sur des
contrats d'emploi et la ville a intérêt
à collaborer accompagner ces gens là
pour également faire le choix de rester
ici parce que c'est des gens qui sont
extrêmement scolarisés et qui amène plus
vu à la communauté montréalaise toujours
cette question de la rétention et là
vous auriez quelque chose de nouveau
alors proposé puis ça va dans le courant
de l'air du temps parce que
niveau maintenant de la numérisation de
nos outils bien sûr nous ne vous arrive
à merci tu pour en témoigner
l'informatique c'est comme ça qu'on
rejoint on se consolera connect nous on
se connecte à la société qu'est ce que
vous avez à proposer d'accord donc
l'autre information qui est intéressante
dans le sondage c'est que dans le groupe
de résidents temporaires
le groupe d'âge qui est le plus
intéressé à faire le choix du québec de
montréal c'est les 18 25 ans et pour
rejoindre ce groupe là il faut
nécessairement et obligatoirement passer
par le numérique donc l'outil qui a été
lancée hier qui s'appelle nouveau départ
c'est un outil personnalisé qui
permettra aux résidents temporaires ou
risban permana d'aller chercher de
l'information personnalisée sur leurs
besoins mais également d'établir des
liens privilégiés avec les personnes
potentielles qui pourront les aider dans
leur intégration et dans la rétention de
nîmes en cas d'accord dont vous arrivez
ici vous êtes un résident temporaire
vous voulez connaître avant tout si vos
diplômes sont reconnus
j'essayais l'étape et donc quelles sont
les modalités
quels sont les autres professionnel a
communiqué ce qu'il ya des gens qui
peuvent vous accompagner dans cette
démarche
deuxième question qu'on se pose
également ceci à d'autres personnes
pourraient amener qu'elles sont des
étapes pour faire la réunification des
familles mais également les ressources
de quartier parce que vous êtes vous
installé dans un quartier c'est un
quartier qui est vivant qui a déjà des
services de proximité en termes de
logement en termes également de loisirs
de plus
tout ça donc toute cette information la
personnaliser dorénavant doit être
disponible sur une plateforme dédiée aux
nouveaux arrivants et c'est comme si
vous aviez un numéro de membre puis un
mot de passe et vous aurez toujours
accès à ces informations
les congressistes et quelque part en
ligne pour vous s'il en est besoin donc
la plateforme initialement une plate
forme qu'il n'essaie pas nécessite pas
de l'authentification dont vous allez là
vous mettez vos profils et on vous donne
l'information mais hatem c'est la
tombola est appelée à évoluer pour
devenir beaucoup plus performant et
surtout hier il y avait beaucoup de
personnes qui circulaient ici pour
justement collecter les impressions et
fin déjà des améliorations elle est
imprimeur hier seulement dans les
quelques heures qui sont circulées si on
a eu 130 like et leur accès très
important de nos jours dans quel la
plateforme a eu 130 la virtuelle des
gens qui sont des maillots on a combien
de l'aigle 2-2 beaucoup c'est très
écouté je suis vraiment ravi de voir que
vous allez avoir 7 ou 6 qui va vous
permettre de mieux connaître le client
parce que après tout si tu es 10 ans
seulement voulu aider ou l'aider mais
vous allez vous aider vous même on va
tous cédé c'est quelque chose qu'il
faudrait s qui est un endroit où peut
aller pour voir ça pour tester pour vous
jouez donc sur le site web de la ville
de montréal on va juste aller chercher
l'onglet nouveau départ en français et
new beginning en anglais et l'autre
primaire et ça c'est une ville qui est
francophone foncièrement maurienne de la
deuxième grande ville frappe fondement
mais en même temps pour cette plate
forme là on a fait pour la première fois
une exception donc il ya oui le support
nargue les mais il ya également un outil
numérique qui est supporté par google
permet la traduction dans plusieurs
langues donc c'est également imprimant
donc la ville de montréal actualise ses
outils numériques pour également
permettre de la visualisation de ces
données en plusieurs langues o de la
france et ça mérite un article de la
part de radio canada international
c'est pas moi qui prends les décisions
mais comme c'est moi qui écris les
articles j'en fais maths est là dessus
alors merci beaucoup à votre tâche
étudiants qui est vice président du
comité exécutif de la ville de montréal
je vous laisse filer vous avez un
univers à conquérir et je voulais
revenir vers christophe berthet
christophe on va tester dans quelques
instants votre salon parce qu'on a mis
tout à l'épreuve
un peu comme ford et gm on a un effet
sur la route met d'abord je voudrais la
tournée vers notre invité mystère vous
le saviez pas que vous étiez l'invité
mystère mais florent pradon est avec
nous de lagence newton bonjour écoutez
donc je vous remercie d'être venus merci
pour l'invitation je ne vous dis pas au
revoir mais plus le double juste
signaler votre arrivée enfin malédiction
qui était prévu donc parce que vous avez
donné une conférence au exactement
[Musique]
brièvement il s'agissait de quoi on
expliquait en fait aux nouveaux
arrivants comme comprendre un peu ce qui
se passe du côté des recruteurs pour
améliorer leur candidature et avoir plus
de succès souvent les candidats se pose
des questions sur pourquoi on me demande
de faire ça pour qu'on me demande de
faire mon cv telle façon 1 pourquoi je
dois être sur linkedin donc là ils ont
l'opportunité de parler avec des
recruteurs et de comprendre ce qu'on
fait dans les coulisses pour être en
mesure d'optimiser leur candidature
le nom votre entreprise c'est newton je
vous promets en revient et même qu'on
passe quelques minutes ensemble parce
que ce que vous avez annoncé moi je
trouve que c'est vraiment ou de vins de
tous alors pour le moment je me tourne
vers laon coanimateur nous parle
beaucoup
oui faut bien parler merci oui explique
s'il vous plaît un christophe à quel
point tu as aimé ou pas aimer les
différents parce que tu as passé les
tests un peu comme une course à
obstacles aujourd'hui bien évidemment
quelqu'un qui vient ici au salon il peut
aider à trouver de l'aide pour remplir
son cv on peut l'aider à prendre une
bonne photographie aux qualités
professionnelles pour dean cain
puis c'est pas tout alors parlez nous de
ce qui était arrivé depuis ce matin
depuis que tu as été accueillis ici par
un copain que tu connaissais pas mais
c'est sa jeunesse à ses bénévoles
il était très bon accompagnateurs il m'a
il m'a bien guidé ma bien orienté et
puis j'ai vite eu un coup de chapeau à
ce que je dirai à christ ans que j'ai
émis j'ai beaucoup aimé ces c'est la
diversité c'est la multiplicité des
exposants et des compagnies qui viennent
d'un peu partout non seulement d'aider
compagnie de montréal et québec mais
aussi de l'extérieur de multinationales
je dirais j'étais marquée par des
compagnies d'assurance
les compagnies de transport de santé et
qui m'ont proposé qui propose également
tout le monde et de nombreux services
je t'ai manqué par l'espace iv ce avec
un nouvel arrivant à peine le témoin la
répétition arrivent au québec et seniors
cvs que c'est la même chose il ya
beaucoup de points d'interrogations on
est un peu perdu mais quand je suis
arrivé devant lui la madame a argué m
kiki makine qui m'a façonné qui me tue
m'a fasciné avec les éléments
nécessaires dans la façon de concevoir
l'espace
les curriculum vitae ici c'était quelque
chose de commandes de particuliers en
trois ans neil pasche - des pages on
peut résumer un cv de de trois pages ça
c'est des éléments que les nouvelles que
les nouveaux arrivants n'auront toujours
pas donc
je préciserai que ça a été un point très
important comme en fait les séries à la
façon québécois est ce que tu as eu
l'occasion de faire ta ta ta photo win
tin sur le oui j'en viens j'y reviens je
parle beaucoup comme stephen hunt je
n'étais que si je sais pas si j'ai une
occasion de fermer ma photo je pense que
je vais encore une fois est au fait mon
profil sur un crime pour optimiser ma
chance d'obtenir et décrocher un emploi
il ya des compagnies qui sont ici
présentés les combien d'exposants
on a cent soixante dix huit exposants
aujourd'hui puis parmi eux il ya des
compagnies qui cherche des gens et
activement
on a à peu près 45 recruteurs qui sont
sur le salon 45 et combien j'en ai
rencontré j'en ai rencontré 7,7 bonne
compagnie
je les nommer que quelques-unes j'ai
rencontré à cette assurance qu est le
numéro 2 a lieu du niveau de l'assurance
aux états unis cet instant garou et
j'invite le chercher d'emploi à y aller
ils vont être évo être fasciné par les
services par de nombreux services qu'ils
offrent donc avant quitté le salon fait
un tour j'ai également été fasciné par
la compagnie cgi qui est une grosse
firme de conseil en technologies de
l'information par ce matériau j'ai
l'information mais aussi à d'autres
services de manufacture de gaz depuis
ton le gars est vraiment un des gros
concurrents aux grosses firmes
internationales que l'on connaît je veux
pas j'ai pas cité le nom ici mais
j'invite également le monde
les chercheurs d'emploi à y aller j'y
aille
j'ai été je veux souligner très très
heureux je prévois d'ailleurs la visite
dans les maritimes cet été je pense que
je vais profiter de l'occasion pour
un bon une bonne compagnie aussi ce
serait gratuit situé pas grand sens
je profite pour découvrir aussi la
partie s maritime atlantique du canada
le dit ans c'est un bel endroit
santé canada qui fait également des
bonnes choses qui également martien
épouse est oui ou non je suis je vais
pas si des j'écouterai parler du salon
j'ai l'habitude de dire je suis le
premier à avoir bénéficié des services
du salon en effet j'ai eu l'idée il ya
je suis arrivé comme vous l'entendez je
suis pas né au lac saint jean
donc je suis arrivée il ya huit ans au
québec et j'ai cherché salon qui
n'existaient pas et donc j'ai eu l'idée
de
de créer donc s'est entouré d'une équipe
et puis petit à petit donc j'allais voir
les entreprises j'ai commencé à discuter
avec elles et toutes les entreprises que
suite que quelques site marsis en effet
j'ai eu l'occasion de les rencontrer
presque tout et leur vendre un petit peu
le projet au départ pour certaines et il
y en a qui nous suivent maintenant
depuis depuis six ans et moi j'ai bâti
mon réseau comme ça en tant que nouvel
arrivant
on allant voir ces entreprises pour le
sol martien il faut expliquer à tout le
monde
qu'est ce qui était arrivé quand tu
étais arrivé à montréal marty un
écouteur radio-canada internationaux
piqué l'année cheikh où il a découvert
depuis 2005 a fait des médecins c'est le
premier contact avec stéphane parce que
c'est un vieil ami je le connais depuis
environ deux ans et cinq questions
canada des questions support de la
config confédération sur le monstre à
obobogo sûr
les eaux sacrées
au québec et au canada
en général donc beaucoup de questions
sur le pays il faudrait aller voir sur
le site de radio canada est en marche
elle peut retrouver certaines de des
collaborations je te faisais ça en
entrevue tout à fait quand tu es tu
arrivé à montréal c'était il ya trois
ans je suis arrivé à montréal
en 2000 en 2014 mon objectif commun
c'était pas du mémorial c'était dans les
deux dans les régions c'est d'aller à en
abitibi témiscamingue
c'est ça moi c'était ça ma 6t savoir que
j'amène mon pays je serai là directement
alloués au lendemain parce que avec une
formation chimie je ne vais je aller
travailler dans les mines joyeux je
voulais rien savoir
bon malheureusement car j'arrive le
secteur du plan n'en est pas n était pas
aussi elle n'était plus aussi à la une
il y avait un peu la baisse des prix des
matières premières des métaux fait qu bo
dans ce marché mondial ce qui fait que
ça c'est un peu ça s'est calmé
donc j'ai dû changer d'orientation je me
suis vivant je vais découvrir montréal
je découvrirai j'ai envie de dire j'aime
bien perdu j'ai plutôt gagné parce que
montréal est une ville où il y a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de compagnies
notamment dans le secteur de la chimie
le c'était quimerc'h qui m a fait parce
que j'ai un baccalauréat en chimie dans
le secteur de la pharmacie c'est la même
famille dans le secteur des nouvelles
technologies dans le secteur du
la construction si je pense qu'on a bien
on a bien lotis au monde
j'aurais là quand tu étais arrivé ici
j'aurais aimé te proposer un emploi en
télécommunications à radio canada parce
que c'est un vieil ami on essaie de
passer ses vieux amis mais je savais pas
que tu écris très bien très bon français
ça mais j'étais pas se passe si c'était
possible de trouver quelque chose facile
mais j'ai pas changer vraiment aller
tellement loin je me suis senti un peu
mea culpa un petit show corrigé meti oui
il n'est jamais trop comment ni dans la
vie ni luc simard adepte avec nous c'est
le directeur la diversité des relations
citoyennes radio canada luc simard c'est
votre travail quelque part je m'étais je
vais mettre des mots dans la bouche mais
toutes nos usines aux fresques ouvrir
avec je pensais le travail d ouvrir
l'école d'art de préparer l'arrivée de
convaincre les patrons de préparer
l'environnement et de remplir la
promesse est ce que ça résume à feu
c'est très bien de stéphane et il ya
beaucoup de travail à faire beaucoup
travaillent dans la composition du
personnel de radio canada parce que nous
n'avons pas en ce moment un personnel
qui reflète très bien la composition de
montréal si on regarde juste les gens
qui sont
ici aujourd'hui ça représente mon frère
on parle de chalon des migrations ou
encore appelée sur le salon montréalais
ça ressemble aux gens qu'on va croiser
tout à l'heure quand on va sortir d'ici
que quand on prend de transport
collectif si le mot rien qu'on voit mais
ce n'est pas le moyen qu'on voit dans
les corridors de radio canada vous savez
comme moi donc il ya un travail à faire
pour diversifier la composition du
personnel d'une part et d'autre part
pour diversifier notre programmation
parce que nous produisons une masse des
missions de contenus d'information vous
le faites à rci mais évidemment les
émissions de télévision qui continue la
radio multiples chaînes et la
programmation qu'on y offre ne reflète
pas très bien non plus la composition du
de montréal et du québec et du canada
d'aujourd'hui parce que bon moi je suis
originaire du saguenay-lac-saint-jean
j'ai postulé l'accent des et quand je
retourne à chicoutimi dont qui s'appelle
saguenay maintenant 12 janvier je vois
quand même qu'il ya eu des changements
sur le plan démographique donc c'est
l'ensemble du canada et du québec les de
ces régions qui change même si bien sûr
la plupart des immigrants s'établissent
ici à montréal
mais le temps fait son effet il ya
maintenant des immigrants que partout
donc ce important à la fois de
diversifier la composition notre
personnel nous faisons est important
mais qui va peut-être pas aussi vite que
j'aimerais parce que c'est une
institution qui a beaucoup d'argent
radio canada 81 ans et parce qu'on a
tous cette enveloppe que la plupart des
gens ce qu'ils finissent par travaillait
radio canada reste longtemps parce
qu'ils aiment s'appeler travail
intéressante un milieu intéressant donc
lieu de travail à faire ce qu'on peut
faire plus vite cependant ces diverses
la programmation et met en avant aussi
dans des visages qu'on voit ou qu'on
entend des gens qui représente la
société montréalaise parce que la
particularité notre
de notre organisation c'est que pour une
personne qui table à l'antenne comme
vous stéphane bern à 99 autres comme moi
qu'on n'entend pas d'habitude c'est
exceptionnel mais qui sont derrière la
scinder de paresse pony à l'écran ni ni
à la radio donc il faut montrer ce 1% à
la pour qu'il représente un peu mieux la
société québécoise et canadienne et ça
ça va tirer les 99% d'autres on a besoin
pour travailler dans tous les autres
métiers que ce soit en technique que ce
soit en production que ce soit en
finance que ce soit en avant et c'est
florian pradon nous y tenir alors moi
j'ai trouvé votre d'abord le site web
toujours bon c'est toujours sympa quand
c'est bien fait
vous êtes un professionnel c'est l'
agence newton oui quelle bonne on
appelle un peu la science parfois un peu
dur malton exactement c'est à la
référence voilà et puis vous êtes
finalement plus avant que les patrons ya
quelque chose chez vous je sais pas si
je suis plus avant que les patrons mais
je me suis donné comme objectif après
dix ans que ça fait dix ans maintenant
que je suis ici à montréal
vous l'attendez mon accent effectivement
n'est pas très maxime lac-saint-jean non
effectivement en arrivant ici donc il ya
dix ans je me suis dit comment je vais
pouvoir redonner à la communauté
et c'est passé par plein plein plein
d'étapes s'est passé par des conférences
des ateliers
merci christophe de m'avoir invité et
pour la deuxième année consécutive
encore donné un atelier à à des gens et
les aider un peu à se trouver de
l'emploi
je dirais que en étant passé par ces
étapes là en étant aussi de l'autre côté
de la barrière en ayant recruté en
entreprise
j'ai vu les deux côtés de la barrière en
fait et ça m'a donné l'idée de dire qu'
on a une problématique on a d'un côté
des candidats qui cherchent un emploi
qui ont quelque chose à proposer
et de l'autre côté on a des entreprises
qui désespérément cherche les bonnes
personnes le je crois je pense que le
taux de chômage des gens en immigration
et doubles et doubles donc il n'y a pas
une pro du nom volonté d'intégrer il ya
une incompréhension dans les façons de
faire
dans les cultures déco des cultures dans
les méthodologies dans les approches qui
font que ça crée des tensions entre les
deux ça permet pas de créer le lien
alors newton l'objectif c'est ça en fait
tu le relevait marthien isaac newton
c'est l'attraction c'est de dire comment
je vais faire pour m'assurer que les
gens quand ils arrivent sur le marché du
travail et qui cherchent un emploi vont
mieux comprendre ce que fait
l'organisation
c'est valable pour des nouveaux
arrivants comme c'est valable pour des
gens des locaux et le problème d
organisation c'est qu'elles doivent
sortir d'un système qui était de dire
j'en vois des offres d'emploi dans
l'espace en espérant avoir et en priant
d'avoir le bon candidat
je tourne ça différemment je raconte
plutôt qui je suis qui est radio canada
par exemple quelles sont nos valeurs
qu'est ce qui nous réunit ensemble
qu'est ce qu'on essaie d'accomplir
qu'est ce que t'en pense à ce que ça
t'intéresserait te joindre à nous
c'est un peu de raconter 7,7 s'est
changé la tournure et la façon dont on
aborde les choses rentrées dans une
conversation et paju dans une
transaction
vous voyez comment je me suis je me
prépare elle à faire depuis longtemps je
voulais que vous rencontriez les une
union quelque chose qui se passe ici l
émission j'espère que vous approfondirez
un peu la faire c'est mon métier à moi
de mettre un contact cette façon les
gens et je vous en remercie ce pas
d'obligation mais quand même poursuivre
et sur le sort sur la lancée de l'élan
j'ai pas terminée une fois qu'on a
offert on a trouvé le candidat qu'on
s'est ouvert qu'on a moins bien fait
comprendre qu' on était véritablement
tombé très curieux par rapport à à ce
que quelqu'un va nous offrir il faut
remplir la promesse exact mais là je
pense que beaucoup de gens comprennent
pas oui c'est un très bon point stéphane
l'enjeu c'est que il compromet des
choses en terme de 2,2 d'accomplissement
ou de réalisation dans l'organisation et
on ne tient pas puis c'est important de
pas se contenter de faire du cosmétique
de des belles vidéos des belles photos
d'organisation et c'est faut aller plus
loin que ça comment aujourd'hui on va
changer notre comportement un recruteur
peut pas avoir la même attitude avec un
nouvel arrivant
ou avec quelqu'un qui connaît le marché
local par exemple il faut qu'il ait une
façon de d'avoir un discours et une
approche des candidatures qui font
campagne exact ce que tu dis martien une
belle façon de la campagne est
exactement je le dis souvent aux
recruteurs puis je le fais un homme dans
mon travail décide conscientiser un
petit peu leur rôle
on l'a vu y'a pas longtemps à l'article
de mostafa la vrigne aux bois y trouver
ça fascinant parce que il dit tout cet
article là il dit qu' ils sont là les
talents ils sont parmi nous mais il faut
vous trouviez une façon d'aller les
approcher mais différemment parler de
mustapha faut expliquer il ya eu
quelqu'un qui était très gentil cette
semaine je pars c'est un attaché
politique gens très importants qui se
manifeste et kimonos dit stéphanie est
espoir de mustapha parue dans le
quotidien la presse et morale et j'ai
été voir la vidéo originale la presse la
rof l'a remis dans son article sur une
autre version facebook j'ai l'original
on consulte et seulement cinq fois mais
la version la prince était consulté dans
plus de 120 m et la fois la ddt
ça fait deux jours j'ai pas regardé
d'accord ça y est c'est un parfum 90
milles en 24 heures alors mustapha son
nom c'est mostafa mais oui tu connais je
connais pas personnellement j'habite son
histoire
parce que jr fils est cher mais si vous
voulez bien nous on l'entendra pas mais
puisque vous connaissez tous les soirs
c'est pas grave mais les gens sur
facebook là vont l'entendre quand ces
masters atp
je connais pas je suis son histoire
récente parce que parce que jr filet
mais si vous voulez bien nous on
l'entendra pas mais puisque vous
connaissez tous les soirs c'est pas
grave
et les gens se présentent l'abondante
ans 12 mbj son histoire qui parce que jr
fils
mais si vous voulez dire c'est pourquoi
nous on n'entendra pas mais puisque vous
connaissez tous les soirs c'est pas
grave
déjà sur facebook
son histoire
c'est parce que j ai filé horde et si
vous voulez bien
pourquoi nous on n'entendra pas mais
puisque vous connaissez tous les soirs
c'est pas grave
moi je sais faire que ça tient dur est
passé parce que je connais pas
régis son histoire qui leur semble
jr fils et or des si vous voulez nous on
n'entendra pas est ce que vous
connaissez tous les soirs c'est pas
grave est déjà sous pression
si son histoire
parce que j ai repris des haies
lors des six poules et bien pourquoi
nous on entendra ce que vous connaissez
tous les soirs c'est pas grave
je dois
son histoire qu'il a
parce que j écrivais
or des si vous voulez bien pourquoi nous
on entendra ce que vous connaissez tous
les soirs c'est pas mal
il est gestionnaire
on l'attend
nous
et c'est toute l'histoire c'est pas là
et je l'assumé
la loi s'applique à toi
nous lançons puisque
sous emprise de génie-conseil je crois
ou en construction et il lui propose un
emploi il lui donne sa chance et son
premier emploi après quatre ans de
travail acharné bon je voulais juste
signaler quelque chose je parle au
technicien le fait rarement observée
dans les directs
j'ai en temps réel sa salle et j'en
attends c'est le plus important
non je vais enlever mes écouteurs orlova
écouteurs qui ont flanché
alors vous disiez parce que moi si je
n'attendais pas peut-être canado confort
attendues je disais que ça s'est bien
terminé effectivement il a trouvé un
emploi dans son domaine
après quatre années de recherches assez
ardue une des leçons à retenir c'est
donc les talents sont bien là il faut
juste prendre le temps d'adapter son
approche en fonction du besoin qu'on a
là ont failli d'une population de 2
nouveaux arrivants il est nécessaire d
adresser différemment et de porter
attention à ces camps d'études
candidature là de manière différenciée
mais c'est pas tout le monde peut faire
des vidéos ou à quoi les faire de
regarder non mais c'est important pour
les candidats de comprendre qu'elle est
nouveaux outils qui vont les aider à se
mettre de l'avant
c'est important qu'ils apprennent à les
maîtriser line tyne c'est la première
étape tout agent il faut comprendre
comment ça fonctionne pour optimiser
donner un maximum je le dis souvent
linkedin c'est une publicité pour vous
24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
et c'est gratuit c'est grave servez vous
en fait c'est très important c'est vrai
il ya une de vos copines qui viennent se
glisser à la table micheline s'est
permis vous savez donc je lance avant
vous présenter je lance un appel général
y reste un siège et en restera deux
probablement là quelques instants ce
qu'ils sont des exposants ici qui ont un
message à livrer à tous les gens autour
de la planète concernant ce salon ou
même aux gens de montréal pourquoi pas
vous pouvez venir vous asseoir sans
présentation tant que vous ne vendez pas
du pepsi ou du coca cola moi j'ai pas de
problème ça ça fait partie du règlement
alors je vais me tourner parce que il ya
mon rédacteur en chef seulement de
mélanie qui ça fait partie du personnel
qui se cache mais qui est toujours là
pour nous aider qui m'a dit il ya sept
personnes à qu'il faut que tu parles
et il a
il ya un salon spécial qui s'organisent
pour les réfugiés qui sont arrivés avec
new york mon dieu depuis le décembre de
l'an dernier il j'ai ici quelqu'un je te
donner la chance de la présenter cette
personne parce que moi je ne vois qu'une
proche elle appelle donc madame fait
nachat qui est conseillère en emploi
bonjour à tous en projet merci stéphane
demeurant donné cette chance je suis
conseiller en emploi au ses saillies
centre social d'être aux migrants qui
existe depuis soixante dix ans à
montréal qui travaille avec
les réfugiés parrainés par l'état donc
nous sommes en train avec la croix rouge
de franck lure un beau projet depuis
l'accueil des personnes réfugiées régie
de la civi
un salon de l'emploi spécial syrien donc
c'est une première je suis fier d'être
impliqué
avec force dans ce beau projet puisque
mu actionnaires non je suis d'origine
marocaine c'est ma dixième et migration
au québec
ma première année en france où j'y suis
resté plus de 15 heures
ça c'est ma deuxième itération et je
suis fier d'apprécier très contente et
très contente de pouvoir aussi partagé
comme 18 tard une autre expérience
autant penny migrants et c'était pas
facile même en tant que travailleurs
qualifiés c'est très difficile en été
sélectionné par rapport à nos diplômes
nos expériences et il faut ici si tout
sauf
c'est tout ça et je dis aux réformes
aujourd'hui pour les réfugiés syriens
malheureusement pour moi des fois je
déteste le fait que je suis conseiller
en emploi puisque j'ai des médecins j'ai
des pharmaciens j'ai des personnes
hautement qualifiées avec plusieurs
années d'expérience où je trouve du mal
à les placer quelque part aujourd'hui il
travaille chez adonis majoritairement
donc sachez que vous êtes servis par des
belles personnes des docteurs des
médecins dont les visées quitté faut si
vous avez un malaise vous serez vraiment
entouré par du personnel de la santé
et je lance un appel si ces permis
stéphane de dire comment aujourd'hui on
trouve du mal à trouver un docteur
généraliste un dentiste alors prendre à
plusieurs parmi nous avec plusieurs
années d'expérience
aujourd'hui je promets pas à ces
personnes ils sont bien conscientes
qu'ils vont trouver dans leur domaine
d'expertisé
on a des ingénieurs dans tout domaine de
l'ingénierie je veux juste d'habitude en
fait un salon de l'emploi
les exposants etc les candidats qui
arrive aujourd'hui c'est les candidats
syrienne qui veulent se faire connaître
c'est pas une discrimination par rapport
à zot à d'autres réfugiés parce que j'ai
aussi ceux qui viennent du congo
djibouti du mozambique et j'en passe
mais aujourd'hui on a une petite
subvention par rapport à cette catégorie
ça n'empêche pas que j'ai intégré par
notre personne c'est c'est l'occasion si
vous avez toujours travaillé comme ça a
changé ma façon de faire on va pas faire
mais c'est vraiment des personnes qu'on
a rencontrés dans quelque 3 conférences
avec ces personnes là et j'étais
surprise positive mans l2 leur
engagement ils sont contents d'être ici
mais sachez qu'ils ont tout perdu ils
ont gardé juste leur diplôme des fois
ils ont même pas le diplôme en papier
ils ont leurs années d'expérience et il
veut garder ça vraiment et aujourd'hui
je leur offre du travail général parce
que quand je suis appelé par un
employeur je suis jamais contente parce
que j'étais derrière qui est du travail
général du man tension 6
usines etc dans les magasins c'est faire
les rayons on a fait un site spécial
pour les immigrants d'origine arabe
radio canada international je pensais en
avril l'an dernier par est justement de
la situation des syriens n'ont pas des
nouveaux arrivants aux nombreux niveaux
mais ceux qui sont là depuis 1981 et
ceux qui ont réussi à s'établir bien
chez nous il occupe des traîne comparé à
d'autres catégories des migrants les
occupent des emplois en gestion par
exemple en pourcentage plus élevé que
dans d'autres sont déjà très éduquée et
on n'en profite pas et je ne veux pas
vous demander si les pas des annonceurs
de radio là parmi le groupe
si jamais j'en avais y pourrait
peut-être nous moi je me dis qu'ils ont
travaillé dans le journalisme
oui bon je peut vous servir
oui il fait de l'envoyer il faut me
l'envoyer celle là
certains d'entre eux gourma carte et je
vais la laisser moi stéphane je vais
devoir y aller nous laisser là dessus je
reviens plus tard c'est abdou mission
salon hockey comme simples participants
pour animer un peu le stand de radio
canada donc j'y serai parti quelqu'un de
fantastique luc simard admis dans des
missions l'applaudît il ya quelques
années de cela dans le coup dans un beau
passez un bon beaucoup du pays à
l'alberta c'est fantastique
l'été quand il fait soleil oui mais
l'hiver c'est hot rod notre soir j'ai
pas terminé je un appel général
si vous êtes un exposant vous avez
quelque chose à annoncer il reste une
place il y en aura deux bientôt n'ai pas
besoin de passer à travers un
fier-à-bras passer directement ici je
voulais bah écoutez vous allez nous
présenter votre votre collègue votre ami
oui avec plaisir
j'ai rencontré micheline ça fait combien
de temps maintenant à au moins quatre
ans au moins 80 sont des événements on a
eu un coup de coeur professionnel et
humain
oui michel fait la promotion du livre
d'affaires et de l'importance du livre
d'affaires c'est important pour les gens
recrutement et ressources humaines de
lire pour se tenir un peu plus informés
aussi des tendances comprendre un peu
mieux d'ailleurs il ya un lit qu'elle va
dont elle va parler que j'ai lu moi même
qui est très important le code québec
pour les migrants comme pour les jambes
ressources humaines je le recommanderais
ce qu'il est possible d'utiliser cette
petite caméra qui ne sert à rien et de
rapprocher le livre de la série caméra
alors avait même présenté alors moi mon
nom et micheline bourque et j'ai créé ce
projet d'affaires qui s'appelle le club
de lecture l affaire je suis exposantes
ici
au salon mais du lac saint jean oui
c'est ça c'est ça je suis plus du côté
de l'est des maritimes
ça fait très longtemps que je suis ici
au québec alors le projet d'affaires que
j'ai crié c'est de créer un carrefour de
l'encan dans la francophonie pour les
adeptes de la littérature d'affaires et
ici je vais présenter une conférence cet
après midi simplement pour animer la
lecture qui est pas de pros titre des
cinq livres que tout nouvel arrivant
doit lire s'il veut travailler et faire
des affaires au québec
alors j'ai mené une collection de cinq
ouvrages québécois bien sûr en partant
c'est pas vraiment un livre d'affaires
mais c'est un livre qui à mon avis était
indispensable qui s'appelle le code
québec qui est relativement récent
ce nouvel âge qui a été publié par les
éditions de l'homme co écrit par jean
marc léger sondages
la jacques nantel grande place aux hec
et pierre duhamel président délégué
général de la fondation de
l'entrepreneurship
alors voilà ça c'est le premier qui
devait se produire mais avec des années
et des années de recherche qui permet de
définir c'est quoi québécois aujourd'hui
c'est très intéressant je pense c'est un
quota à 7.7 moi c'est ça c'est les sept
différences qui font de nous un peuple
unique mais finalement il a joué 70 pour
cent de canadiens anglais de 29 % qui
restent c'est ça qui nous distingue
oui je jeûnais
je gardais passer à la télé oui des
émissions de
en france l'émission dimanche qui
rassemble je pense que c'est tout le
monde tout le monde en face il a
consulté bien écrit bien documenté c'est
de la recherche s'est bien étoffé je
reprends certains autres oui vous avez
saint louis va pas faire ça mais j'ai
pensé que c'était important de jeter un
coup d'oeil sur la situation des femmes
notre collègue marie louise arsenault a
publié les guilidoux finir tu demeures
antastique de crier au loup qui
s'appelle l'abécédaire du féminisme donc
de a à z des thèmes qui porte sur la
situation des femmes
mais c'est aussi un livre que je
recommande pas juste pour de messages
qui ce qui sous-entend dit là dedans
mais c'est parce qu'il ya plein
d'histoires haye appelée différence sur
la culture sur l'actualité les
personnages publics
l'histoire du canada tant l'histoire du
québec et du canada s'assure donc il ya
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de contenu
c'est pas juste un lead qui fait
l'apologie du féminisme
quoique le message est clair alors je
trouve que c'est important de prades rsa
dans la discussion avec des nouveaux
arrivants un livre pratico pratique sur
des codes comment bien se comporter
l'étiquette faire une bonne impression
clippard une cabine par keith julie
boulet comment projeté confiance et
crédibilité
spécialiste de l'étiquette de pote
d'affaires intéressant on aime beaucoup
la recevoir avec la connaissent pas mais
parce qu il faut faire des entrevues
avec quelques oies pour savoir comment
manger at her exactement d'oiseaux très
petit couplet
je mange plus depuis ce temps il vient
tout juste de sortir et qui s'appelle le
sixième talents de tous les livres que
j'ai lus s'anime j'en lis beaucoup
celui ci a eu un effet sur moi donc
l'idée de se tourner vers soi pour
découvrir ses talents et avec cette
connaissance là aller de l'avant
justement pour les mettre
donc ce livre est très bien écrit qu'il
fait un bon clin d'oeil à newton à il
utilise beaucoup d'anecdotes donne lui
une théorie et là ils reviennent sur la
vulgarisation en utilisant les analogies
de newton et un dernier qui viennent
prof universitaire monsieur louis
jacques filion entre le plan des savoirs
son tour et ça y est tout juste de
sortir qui fait l'histoire qui nous
présente le parcours de grands
entrepreneurs québécois et moi et grands
donc jean coutu les wathier et
d'entreprises moins connus donc si on
veut travailler et faire des affaires au
québec
c'est important de connaître les grands
et grands entrepreneurs ceux qui ont
fait de grandes choses et ceux qui ont
pris des entreprises en régions ou dans
des domaines un peu comme des modèles 6
à des modèles gens alors je trouve qu'il
est important de s'approprier ce langage
là il ya un message particulier par
rapport à un rôle de son tour un message
particulier ne se lève et que je prie
intéressant donc c'est les histoires des
bâtisseurs du québec
moi je bâtis avec marseille infos sur
wii pour toutes très bien aujourd'hui
marçais est ce que tu peux m'aider pour
les ici oui je le fais je ne la connais
pas elle est très jolie mais ce n'est
pas l'essentiel reste on va créer de bax
ont vaincu devant scotia michel bouquet
c'est moi ça pardon à ce que j'en sais
ça fait partie de plaisir oui c'est ça
du plaisir en me flaud rien je pense oui
alors présenté au croquet je suis je
travaille pas contre ça des filles
ces dernières années aujourd'hui chez
exposants pour vous rapprocher du micron
oui j'ai aujourd'hui je suis exposantes
à la banque scotia et on est là en fait
pour offrir une gamme de produits pour
les nouveaux arrivants qu'ils soient
étudiants résidents permanents ou
travailleurs étrangers caméra portable
ici pour qu'on manque le stan qui est
directement en arrière notre invité est
exactement fait que là on est là
aujourd'hui pour leur expliquer les
services financiers comment ça
fonctionne au canada et qui rend dans
une des offres vraiment très
intéressante pour eux ils viennent nous
voir pour voir comment ça fonctionne un
compte bancaire une carte de crédit et
qui était radieuse et très différent de
leur pays d'origine
c'est très important de les guider de
les accompagner on peut le faire sur
place ou tout simplement se présenter en
succursale pour compléter la procédure
ça fait la troisième année consécutive
qu'on est présent au salon une très
grande banque canadienne présente aussi
au niveau international
vos collègues y a-il temps là pour
m'encourager alors on est très contents
de les accompagner et leur offrir ce
qu'ils ont besoin en fait en termes de
produits finances
très bien est ce que vous pourriez me
faire une faveur c'est rare normalement
on a une grosse équipe est là
aujourd'hui on a un petit budget il ne
manque qu'une personne
j'ai besoin que vous alliez au stade de
parcs canada qui se trouve directement à
la fière de moi ils m'ont promis de
participer à l'émission aujourd'hui ils
ont même fait une demande officielle de
guerre et puis on les voit pas et se
cachent ils sont quatre et on leur a
demandé où venir un gros coup tout seul
on sait peu mais fort vous allez les
chercher
d'accord c'est c'est très gentil bon non
vous rester assise va coûter moi j'ai
besoin d'eux est-ce que je vais vous
présenter un français qui a écrit en
libye si qui vit au canada depuis dix
ans c'est mon bon ne cet après midi
venait alors c'est un français écrit un
livre qui s'appelle une des cyniques
canadienne à compte d'auteur allait
quand même vite et ça fait les grands
programmes viderait c'est un auteur en
devenir
j'ai voulu faire un petit coup un petit
coucou aux g parce que il explique bien
dans son propre langage son expérience
de vie ici au canada
je pense qu'il est ici encore un très
bon moment est grave je pense que le
québec ça vous plaît après avoir fait
énormément de voyagement ici au canada
alors un petit coucou agréable oui
bonjour un bon jour en jour oui
effectivement je me plaît beaucoup au
canada je suis même devenu canadien le
plus vite possible
ok ça fait mal en 16 ans
au québec je suis d'abord arrivé à
montréal j'ai passé un an - et ensuite
je suis allée à québec
et puis là je me suis vraiment beaucoup
plus et puis bon bain en fonction du
travail et puis avec ma femme on est
revenu à montréal au bout de quelques
années
enfin on a quand même passé huit ans à
québec et là on est dans l'île a décidé
qu'à l'arrière
mon livre s'appelle une décennie
canadienne oui je viens de publier un
livre s'appelle une décennie qui
deviennent merci je les choisis parce
que c'est dans le langage et quant aux
migrants à bbc au canada commandez une
tasse de café ou une expression il est
tout de langue des problèmes de langage
qui ce qui se présente juste plein de
nouveautés à découvrir
il explique très bien dans son livre un
petit parcours qui veut voyager vraiment
partout au québec
exemple ça parce que j'ai martien il
connaît ça aussi pourra partager avec
vous a les bras un exemple un exemple de
particularités au niveau de la langue
qui fait qu'on est aux os et aux niveaux
des par exemple pas forcément de la
langue mais d'une des marques qu'on
découvre dans l'est dans les magasins
j'avoue que j'ai un peu pris au dépourvu
c'est l'accent l'accent qui m'a le plus
marqué quand on arrive ici on a un
accent on a un accent français
moi en plus j'ai un accent parisien de
maudit par là c'est terrible mais
pourtant les gens m'ont bien acceptée et
puis je suis devenu bilingue québécois
français avec les bureaux français et et
voilà donc quand je suis arrivé lé les
plus grandes difficultés c'était moins -
la langue l accent ou les que la
découverte d'un nouveau style de vie en
réalité même même si en france on vit de
la même manière pratiquement qu'ici en
réalité ça reste une aventure
c'est vraiment une grande aventure
l'immigration est arrivé ici dans un
pays où moi j'ai considéré que tout
allait bien ici c'est vraiment un pays
merveilleux
les gens vivent bien on n'a pas de réel
problème il n'y a pas énormément de
chômage par exemple l'économie roule
les gens sont très positives et c'est ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on découvre en
arrivant ici et qui qui nous contamine
quand je retourne en france
les gens me prennent presque pour un
gars naïf super ouvert et puis tu ne
t'en content de passer
c'est vraiment incroyable j'essaye de le
redire là bas bomba venez ici au canada
j'en ai quelques uns le code québec les
québécois sont plus optimistes
l'invention par florian c'est exactement
un trait de caractère comme par exemple
quand j'ai dit que j'allais lancer
l'activité newton les réactions de mes
amis proches québécois c'était
formidable mais qu'est ce que tu vas
faire mais c'est quoi l'idée derrière ça
génial mais tu tu as tu pensé de faire
ça quand j'ai parlé à des amis à paris
ils m'ont dit mais tu es sûr ouais à
l'étranger gros risques mais pourquoi tu
fais ça tu étais bien payés et était
dans une bonne compagnie pourquoi tu te
lances là dedans mais c'est pas mal mais
c'est vraiment un changement radical de
perspective et de façon de voir le
saisit pas quand on aime on reste dedans
papy c'est un piège pour les français
c'est vrai parce qu'on pense que comme
on parle français
on est on a exactement le même la langue
il comportement lasse aussi beaucoup
alors que pas du tout en fait
ici on est en amérique du nord donc et
ça oui on parle français mais il ya une
culture qui va avec son jeu biechlin
je veux pas vous laisser poser une
troisième question le sixième là parce
que l'oeuvre soit vous payez un cachet
alors pour rester la phase de poules et
s'il avait d'autres personnes voulaient
la schl merci de m'avoir donné
l'occasion de présenter j'avais des
gencives elvire d'élite de faire
découvrir le clip de lecture à faire
site web
oui on produit également le sommet du g8
une initiative pour le salon du livre
international de dans la francophonie
salut à l'automne dans ce médiateur vous
l'avez dit trouver à sommet du nord les
sites web club de lecture affaires.com
si j'en remercie beaucoup à sa merci
puis écouter qu'est ce que fait cette
jeunesse ici sont beaucoup plus jeunes
que nous montrer deux tiers de la mer
jamais
richard riche en culture j'ai appris du
soleil ou est-ce que vous travaillez
prendre du soleil comme ça il y fait que
pleuvoir ici au québec depuis quelques
temps ce sont des jeunes qui
appartiennent à parcs canada
effectivement est-ce que vous appartenez
vous travaillez pour pâques on travaille
pour parcs canada cet été exclusivement
c'est un emploi qui est qui étudiant
donc une donne la chance de faire partie
d'une équipe de diffusion urbaine donc
la prof à la promotion des parcs
nationaux et des lieux historiques
nationaux qu'à nazis dont conseil
promouvoir le patrimoine canadien au
sein de
[Musique]
dans une ville comme montréal par
exemple on essaie d'inviter les gens
sortiront d'ici de montréal visitez la
nature canadienne parce qu'on a des
beaux joyaux aussi au canada qu on
essaye de faire la promotion
c'est une année pas comme les autres la
150 ans c'est spécial csbj que c'est
l'anniversaire du canada ils ont profité
encourage les gens à découvrir ces
bikers découvrir le jardin qui ici au
canada à explorer
n'hésitez pas juste les endroits les
l'historique les parcs nationaux les
conservation marine
lorsque les gens connaissent pas les
services que conan donne donc on est ici
pour en profiter pour venir offrir les
yeux que nabucco de service puis ça beau
ça vaut la peine à profiter
j'avais un petit accent sur lac saint
jean la leur marque mais est ce que ça
prenait des qualifications spéciale pour
représenter par canada cette semaine
auprès de la population
bah c'est sûr que ont été passés sous la
loupe nos pensées des entrevues mais je
pense que c'est vraiment dans l'emploi
qui est con on vise les étudiants quand
c'est pour donner la chance aux
étudiants de montréal de d'occuper un
emploi cet été
donc c'est vrai non plus qui était qui
visait on n'est que des étudiants dans
notre équipe il ya quelques équipes
aussi d'autres équipes mais serein
d'emploi qui vise les étudiants de façon
générale vous avez laissé les filles de
côté c'est de les décider passé au bac
les gars passe et puis les filles
rappelez vous avez deux compagnes oui
aujourd'hui on y en a on a fait douze
équipes en est seulement à 6 aujourd'hui
je pense que c'est lionel dans un peu
une question je pense qu'ils étaient
plus jeunes et de devenir se présentent
au micro tout aussi elliptique nous ne
nous est pas mon poil vérifier c'est
peut-être même plus peut-être même plus
parce que là où j'en suis je les apporte
aussi mais pour revenir un petit peu sur
le 150e anniversaire du canada cette
année exclusivement de la force
découverte qui est une passe en fait qui
permet qui donne accès aux sites
nationaux aux parcs nationaux au site
historique
comment faire les canadiens sont les
bienvenus à ça à l'obtenir en fait c'est
de s'inscrire sur le site du
gouvernement du canada
c'est possible de faire une demande à ce
moment là pour l'obtenir ils ont pu la
libérer gratuitement chez vous fige
temps ça donne accès à tous les tous les
sites tous les parcs nationaux tous ses
sites pour véhicules
c'est bon pour un vécu exactement donc
assez accroché sur le rétroviseur qui ça
donne accès à 5 5 ou 7 personnes
indépendantes un pc ou un gros véhicule
dans this comme ça fonctionne c'est très
bien donc on ferme cette émission
spéciale avec vous un avec parcs canada
150 1 alors allez visiter l'époque sorti
dehors
moi j'habite à l'accord par les
bienvenus on vous encourage les lieux
historiques et les fantassins pas parmi
tous nos soldats qui ont combattu avec
nous aujourd'hui à l'émission l'anneau
spécialiste de l'immigration et de
l'intégration il y en a qu'un qui est
qui reste qui j'ai tenu le coup
lorient oui votre conférence est
terminée ça va terminer avant un peu
après midi weight
on avait beaucoup de questions non ça
pour qu'on puisse de temps puis c'est
fini pour vous vous rentrez chez vous
c'est terminé oui je repars aider des
clients
cette fois ci ah oui les accompagner oui
c'est pas plus dit
radio canada fait partie du lot j'ai
bien compris j'aimerais bien j'aimerais
bien j'ai d'ailleurs des connexions
particulière avec radio-canada chère à
mon coeur puisque j'ai le directeur
général du numérique
maxime st-pierre qui est un ancien de la
compagnie j'ai travaillé newman
donc il est très au fait là vous
connaissez luc aussi parce que le nuc et
merci de jeu où je dis tout de suite
moi j'ai travaillé avec lui donc il n'y
a pas de gêne parfait n'a jamais embêté
et puis je peux pas l'appeler lui dire
comment faire son boulot au patron bah
oui mais je vous le suggère de garder le
contact n'est pas parce que c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui est convaincue de
ce qui me fait que ça aura aussi pour
vous surtout dans des métiers le
mentionner tout à l'heure dans les
métiers technologiques à radio canada
international on est pas on n'a pas de
jeu parce qu'on n'a pas tout à fait de
mieux culpa à faire au sujet de
l'intégration parce que on et saint clar
et tout le monde et de couleurs
différentes je suis amérindiens de ma
grand mère et de mon grand père du bébé
que la famille c'est mon héritage effet
j'y tiens mais on est tous différents
les autres tu viens de à l'argentine
marciel tu appartiens pas encore au
service de la canada sait-on jamais
c'est au hameau jeu dans tous les sens
très bons coups a dit m ça ferait
plaisir ce serait bien des choses de
l'âme de la vie touchait de bonnes
chances mais je sais qu'il ya deux ans
d'employeurs qui s'intéressent un peu
petit peu à toi qui ont semblé être
ouverts santé canada et santé canada
usines et qui cgi cgi et s'ils devaient
être embauchées faut mais on va mettre
un message spécial et la nature et non
là dessus bon alors c'est fini merci
beaucoup à tout le monde de nous avoir
accueillis si gentiment ici le service
français de radio canada international
nous étions nous sommes toujours mais
pour quelques secondes seulement au
palau palais de la civilisation pas
encore ce sera l'an prochain à ottawa
mais au salon des congrès de montréal
le cadre de ce 6e salon de l'immigration
et de l'intégration des nouveaux
arrivants ici au québec
merci beaucoup à l'équipe qui organise
madame paule y est
et puis à christophe également son vice
président qui nous ont tendu la perche
et on a accepté l'invitation
et puis je suis sûr qu'à d'autres
personnes auxquelles on pourrait faire
un discours ou deux mais moi je reçois
les bénévoles les bénévoles les accords
personnel et professionnel qui donne de
l'option qui sont ici on les a les
professionnels qui donnent de leur temps
pour aider les nouveaux arrivants les
immigrants à s'intégrer à trouver de
l'emploi
ce masque spécial au circuit c'est un
caillou qui a été un ex l'accompagnateur
un excellent guide a été un bénévole il
l'a suivi christian c'était les deux
chefs jean belge
effectivement il est d'origine belge pas
vraiment une bonne réception lui
histoire à raconter
il ya toujours des difficultés dans la
vie des mois ça prend du temps à régler
mais ceci fait partie de la solution
une partie de la solution ici stéphane
parent à la semaine prochaine à la
semaine prochaine